بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الاخ العزيز خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود رئيس القمه
العربيه اخي صاحب السمو الملكي الامير
محمد بن سلمان ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس
مجلس الوزراء
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
معالي الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
الحضور الكرام
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
على بركه الله نجتمع اليوم في ضيافه اخينا
خادم الحرمين الشريفين حفظه الله
للنجدد العزم
ولنواصل مسيره العمل العربي المشترك
اراده حره
وتصميم ذاتي وبروح التضامن الجماعي المخلص
كي نؤسس للاستقرار والرخاء والوئام الذي
لا بد ان تنعم به شعوبنا
وسبيلنا لتحقيق ذلك
نهج السلام العادل والشامل وهو نهج لا
بديل له
لمعالجه كافه القضايا العالقه بضمان الامن
والاستقرار والمصالح الحيويه
لازدهار دول المنطقه دون استثناء
ونرحب اشد الترحيب
بالمساعي العربيه الجاده التي نجد فيها
بوادر مبشره لبلوره نظام اقليمي
متجدد ومتوازن
والمتمثله في استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه
واستمرار الهدنه الانسانيه في اليمن
والجهود الجاده لحل ازمتها والجهود الجاده
لحل ازمتها
والعود الحميد للشقيقه سوريا الى بيت
العرب الكبير
ونؤكد على هذا الصعيد ضروره وقف
الاشتباكات المسلحه في السودان
وعوده امنه واستقراره
وحفظ حقوقها المشروعه
الى جانب حقوق الشقيقه مصر في مياه النيل
وبالعمل على استكمال مسيره السلام
للوصول لحل عادل للقضيه الفلسطينيه
وهو حل الدولتين وفق مبادره السلام
العربيه
وبما يضمن حق الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق في
اقامه دولته المستقله
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه
ايها الاشقاء النمتنا العربيه
بتاريخها العريق وقيمها الدينيه
والانسانيه
والحضاريه
وما تتمتع به من ثروات بشريه
وكفاءات مبدعه وموقع استراتيجي مميز
وموارد طبيعيه متنوعه لا هي قادره على
النهوض
والتقدم لمواكبه حركه العصر
عبر تعزيز التكامل العربي
وبتجديد شراكاتها
الاستراتيجيه مع الدول الحليفه والصديقه
القائمه على حفظ المصالح المشتركه
وبرؤيه توافقيه وسياسات اكثر فاعليه
للتصدي للارهاب
ووقف الحروب وتهديدات اسلحه الدمار الشامل
وصولا لمنطقه مستقره تزدهر في محيطها قيم
التعايش الانساني
والتقارب الديني والحضاري
ومن هنا فاننا نعرب
عن خالص تمنياتنا بان تنجح جهودنا
المشتركه في تحقيق السلام بين روسيا
واوكرانيا لعوده الامن والسلم لشعوب
البلدين والدول المجاوره
وليستعيد العالم عافيته
الاقتصاديه والبيئيه التي تنهكها اله
الحرب
كما ويحدون الامل
بان يحالف التوفيق والنجاح
اعمال مؤتمر الاطراف في اتفاقيه الامم
المتحده
الاطاريه
بشان تغيير المناخ كوب 28
الذي سيقام على ارض دوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده الشقيقه في نهايه العام الجاري
باذن الله
واننا اذ نشكر كل من اخينا خادم الحرمين
الشريفين
وصاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس
مجلس الوزراء على هذه الدعوه الكريمه
وعلى حسن الضيافه وكرم الوفاه
نتوجه لهما بعظيم التقدير على ما تبذله
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
من جهود دبلوماسيه فائقه الاهميه
ومبادرات انسانيه عظيمه التاثير
والاثر لعوده امن واستقرار دول المنطقه
وحفظ سيادتها ووحده مواقفها
ولا يفوتنا كذلك
ان نتقدم بالشكر الجزيل الى فخامه الرئيس
عبد المجيد تبون على اسهاماته الطيبه في
تعزيز العمل
العربي المشترك لدى تراس الجمهوريه
الجزائريه الديمقراطيه الشعبيه
اعمال القمه الحاديه والثلاثين
وان نعرب عن خالص الامتنان لمعالي الامين
العام
جامعه الدول العربيه
وجميع منتسب الامانه العامه على حسن
الاعداد والتحضير
لاعمال هذا الاجتماع
سائلين المولى عز وجل
ان تشهد اعمال هذه القمه المباركه
كل توفيق ونجاح
تحقيقا لما نصبو اليه من اهداف خيره تعود
بالمنعه والرفعه لدولنا وشعوبها
كما يطيب لنا ان نعرب في ختام حديثنا
عن ترحيبنا بكم في بلدكم مملكه البحرين
الاجتماعات القمه العربيه المقبله في
عشرين اربعه وعشرين بعون الله تعالى
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات